[Music]
thank you for joining us
today we're really excited to talk with
you about bringing your kubernetes
clusters to Google cloud but before we
dive in we want to introduce ourselves
my name is Ian chacras and I'm an
engineering manager in gke and our team
is making it possible for you to manage
and monitor all of your kubernetes
clusters whether they're in the cloud or
on-premise I've been working with
kubernetes for several years and I've
lived through different tech transitions
for example from bare metal to
containers and monoliths to micro
services and I've seen the velocity that
these modern technologies provide by
allowing you to concentrate and focus on
your core business I'm a product manager
on gke I've been on the team for about
two and a half years now and for the
past year I've been focused on providing
a fantastic multi cluster experience for
anthos customers I'm excited to be on
stage to talk to you about our latest
offering and I'll hand it back to you in
to get us started
all right before proceeding I do need to
reiterate this safe harbor statement we
are talking about many forward-looking
products of varying maturities and the
products and the timelines are subject
to change now that I've told you about
the safe harbor we can dig into the talk
about bringing your kubernetes clusters
to Google Cloud gke is already our
favorite place for kubernetes and I'm
sure I'm sure you've heard about the
announcements related to anthos and GK
on-prem and how these are connected to
Google
we understand that you our customers
have chosen kubernetes to enable you to
move fast we understand that you're you
have to operate in many different
environments and we want to meet you
wherever you are
anthos was built to help you quickly
develop manage and operate your business
and today we're excited to talk about
connecting all your kubernetes clusters
no matter where they are
okay thanks Ian
so we're going to start out today by
exploring the problems based a bit more
we're going to see what
as you're facing and show how anthos can
help address those challenges he and
will study the second thing we'll do is
Ian will give a technology deep dive so
you can learn a little bit more about
the product and we'll find the end with
some demo so you can have more concrete
view of what we're doing to get started
with Swiss focus on the first section
though which is the problem statements
so when we talk to you we often hear a
very similar message in order to be
successful your business and IT
organization needs to be able to adapt
to rapidly changes rapid changes in
consumer demand and you also have to
create competitive edge we know you need
to do this simultaneously in multiple
clouds and on-premises while also
reducing risk and costs this is a tough
challenge but it's not impossible micro
services and containers can help make
your developers and operators more
productive and kubernetes in combination
with anthos can help you run more
efficiently in these multiple
environments first let's dive in to find
out how micro service can help you
achieve better velocity in the VM and
bare metal era applications were built
as monoliths they had very little
component modularity in it and it was
very difficult to actually build and
release so this totally made sense given
the tools and solutions that were
available however it really wasn't the
best way to build and release software
services you know monoliths tend to be
built and qualified as one unit and so a
bug in one part of the code can hold up
an entire release and as a result teams
tend to move more slowly when they're
building monoliths microservices helped
fix this issue they allow you to break
apart your services to introduce much
more modularity teams can then operate
independently from one another releasing
their pieces at their own pace and they
really only need to focus on making sure
that their API is remained stable
however to be effective micro services
also require different packaging and
runtime mechanism
hence containers with containers you can
put all your micro services and their
all the dependencies into ones into
small immutable images these allow you
to reuse the same binaries when
developing testing and production izing
your workloads this makes it easier and
faster to develop and debug and as a
result developers and operators can
focus more on development
instead of managing and patching
infrastructure okay so we've gone over
microservices containers and this
finally brings us to kubernetes
kubernetes is a lot of things to help
running containers and microservices
efficient but today we'll focus on one
key aspect needed to move quickly in
multiple environments that kubernetes
provides an abstraction for the
underlying infrastructure and this is
super important with kubernetes you can
learn one technology one set of api's
and apply it anywhere that kubernetes
runs you can develop common tooling that
works across all environments and this
will really give you the ability to run
your applications of fiction efficiently
in cloud and on-premises next we'll fine
spend a few minutes discussing why you'd
want to run in multiple environments in
the first place this mostly falls into
four use cases modernizing in-place
offering choice for both the
organization and the developers in
within your organization tackling local
compute needs and finally technical
needs the first use case modernizing in
place usually has two facets to it the
first one is data gravity your data
tends to be collected and placed in one
location or in a few locations and it's
very costly and time-consuming it to
move it around to wherever your compute
happens to be at the time and also
legacy services play into this as well
like for example mainframes and database
and other services it really just cannot
easily be moved to cloud they're sort of
just stuck where they are and you have
to live with them but you'd still like
to adopt modern development and
operating practices around those pieces
that cannot move to cloud and you'd like
to use the same tooling in cloud and
on-premises and so you turn to
kubernetes to do exactly this now you
can modernize your applications at your
own pace and move to cloud if or when it
makes sense
the second use case we find often is
choice and if it's like I said it has
two facets one is developer choice you
tell us all the time that each cloud has
its own set of managed services that are
really aren't found anywhere else an
example of this is bigquery it's only
available in GCP and some teams within
your organization might really want to
use this this service but there might be
another team in another part of
organization or even on the same team
that wants to use another cloud
providers product and so it's really
important to give your teams a choice so
they can choose the tools that are most
suited for the project that they're
they're working on another one you've
told us is really important to you as a
voiding vendor lock-in you want to
ensure that you're not tied to any
single cloud provider and then you and
that means that you have to choose a
software stack that allows your
applications to be portable the third
main use case is local compute needs and
this often comes up in kind of industry
verticals so we've seen it in industrial
and retail for one in industrial it
tends to be manufacturing warehouse
automation natural resource exploration
and many others that I haven't listed
here where it's critical to provide
compute near to where it's being
consumed in the retail side it's also
somewhat of a similar need in
brick-and-mortar stores you need to have
local compute for enhancing customer
experience use cases examples of this
are digital signage point-of-sale
systems credit card processing and other
emerging use cases again that I have not
listed here here it's also critical to
provide compute near where it's being
consumed
sometimes we see it for availability but
there's also many other reasons as well
it's a bit different from the industrial
use case because there's likely more
locations its brick-and-mortar so
there's lots of retail stores
potentially in each location likely has
a smaller footprint Hardware looks a bit
less like what you'd find in traditional
data center it's usually lighter weight
and remote management in the retail
environment is super important because
your IT organizations because you need
to meet some sort of technical or
business need for your services that
you're offering to your own customers to
do that you need to run multiple
environments to provide low latency
round-trip times for your services
potentially or maybe you have a high
bandwidth application that really needs
to be very close to to the where the
data is being consumed or maybe you have
to provide
resilience against outages either in
your clusters your whatever environment
is or the entire cloud okay so we went
over how micro-services containers and
kubernetes can help improve velocity we
saw the reasons why you'd want to run
workloads anywhere but how do you
actually work effectively and
efficiently in all of these environments
and that's why we built anthos at a high
level it's a software stack that uses
kubernetes and foundation and with
services built on top of it this makes
managing hybrid and multi cloud
environments easy
at its core Anthes is made up with three
main components they set a cloud
services provided by Google a
marketplace of third-party solutions and
a control plane for managing these
various environments on the compute side
which is the part at the bottom of the
slide here we've got three environments
this is examples we've got cheek GCP
on-prem and another cloud providers in
the idea behind this is this stack
allows you to write once deploy in any
cloud achieve developer and operator
consistently consistency across
environments increase workload mobility
modernize your applications in place or
wherever they need to be modernized and
accelerate developer velocity as a whole
for this talk we're going to focus on
this box I've got here in red it's
really the connection between the
clusters running in each one of these
environments specifically the kubernetes
clusters and we're going to focus on
observing and managing workloads across
those clusters if you're an existing
Anthes customer using GK on Prem you're
actually familiar with this technology
already if what we're using to connect
GK arm preps on Prem clusters to the
cloud what we're offering today is we're
announcing today is an alpha feature for
anthos that allows you to view and in
dip you late
your kubernetes workloads using the GCP
cloud console and it's any kubernetes
cluster I'll now hand it over to you in
who will go through some of the
technology we've developed
thanks Matt thanks for announcing making
that announcement
and I'm gonna tell you a bit about the
technology behind this and then we're
gonna be able to get to a bunch of
different demos so I'm gonna start by
talking about the cloud console and then
talk about the technology that actually
connects clusters to Google the Google
cloud console is a single pane of glass
for all your GK clusters and we're
extending it to support kubernetes
clusters anywhere in gke on-prem all
these clusters show up right alongside
your existing gke on cloud clusters this
single pane of glass allows you to
manage and monitor your workloads in the
same way no matter where they are you
can dig into each of the different
clusters and cluster resources for
example the version of kubernetes and
the nodes that make up that particular
cluster you can view and inspect the
different workloads for example what is
deployed within each of the different
clusters the version of the different
pods and containers as well as the
status and the health of the different
kubernetes objects the gke UI also
provides additional context and surfaces
relevant information for example if
you're debugging and you have trouble
scheduling workloads or workloads or
pending or continued container images
that can't be pulled this information is
brought to the forefront by the UI if
you have sufficient permissions you can
also manipulate resources directly from
the UI for example scaling up a
deployment when you expect to have more
traffic or you need higher redundancy
the cloud console provides this
consistent UI for your admins and your
developers across clouds and across
clusters so now that I've told you about
the UI I'm going to tell you about
connecting your clusters to Google to
register your clusters with Google you
install an agent inside your kubernetes
cluster when you're using GK on créme
this registration occurs automatically
when you create the cluster if we look
at the image on the right in the bottom
half this is actually your
infrastructure with your kubernetes
clusters
with kubernetes API servers in them the
top house this is Google so you run this
agent within your cluster and it reaches
out to Google the cluster and the API
server do not need to have any public
IPS or be publicly accessible so you can
keep your clusters private the agent
itself can traverse VPNs
Nats firewalls and proxies and if for
any reason the agent gets disconnected
it will periodically attempt to
reconnect to Google so now that I've
told you about connecting to Google I'm
going to tell you about how we secure
those communications so the connection
between the agent and Google is
authenticated and authorized using a GCP
service account looking at the diagram
on the right within the cluster near the
agent you have that key and the little
cloud icon this actually is the
credentials for a service account and it
unlocks the service on the Google side
the LOC above it the service account is
burnt bound with specific permissions
that allow the agent to connect to your
project at Google
after this connection is established it
is secured using TS TLS and SSL TLS
provides the integrity and the
encryption of all the communications
between the agent that is running in
your cluster and Google this service
also supports advanced security features
like VPC service controls via cloud
interconnects that will allow you to
restrict from where your agents connect
to Google and now that we've got a
cluster connected we can talk about
logging in so when you visit a cluster
in the cloud console you'll be prompted
to log in to those clusters each user
logs into a cluster individually because
the log in is specific to that user so
similar to the prior diagram we have a
key and that is actually at a laptop at
the cloud console and that is a
kubernetes credentials for the cluster
it unlocks capabilities on the API
server within the cluster - which is
connected
so when you log in you are logging in as
you and the permissions that you have
within that cluster are based upon your
role based access controls or are back
and the key is your credentials so you
when you log in you are actually
interacting with the cluster and you are
authenticated as you and you are
authorized to perform different actions
as you on the cluster itself one of the
benefits of this mode is that all of the
interactions that you have with the
kubernetes api server are audit logged
at that kubernetes api server the other
thing is that administrators can control
what permissions you are authorized to
do the cloud console supports multiple
different ways to log into clusters for
example using basic authentication like
a username and password as well as
kubernetes service account tokens we'll
also be offering o ID c and supporting
Active Directory for logins soon
administrators can use our back
permissions to scope what users can
perform at a minimum to log in users are
required to have view and node reader
permissions and this is simply so you
can see anything about the cluster and
the basics of that cluster if you are
granted higher permissions you can see
more and you can do more for example if
you're granted cluster admin permissions
you can view and manipulate most of the
resources within the kubernetes cluster
and now that I've told you about
securely logging into your clusters and
interacting with them I'm sure you've
got some other questions so the first
question is probably going to be can i
connect my kubernetes clusters so there
are a few things that you'll need before
you can connect your clusters to Google
one you'll need to contact your sales
representative to get involved in the
Alpha on the other hand if you are an
anthos or gke on-prem customer you'll
already be using these capabilities you
will need to have a Google account so
that you can log in you will also need
your clusters to have connectivity back
to Google so that the agents can form
the
action once your cluster is connected
you'll need credentials to log into that
cluster to be able to interact with it
you can connect clusters with a variety
of different kubernetes versions
presently we support kubernetes 110 111
112 and 113 these are the same versions
of kubernetes that are supported on gke
and the cloud console supports these now
you may be wondering what types of
clusters can I connect you can connect
GK clusters from other projects your GK
on Prem clusters are automatically
connected and we've connected a wide
variety of different clusters running
both on cloud and on-premise for example
on AWS as your kubernetes engine and
even OpenShift and now that I've told
you about the different types of
clusters that you can connect I'm going
to hand it back to Matt all right thanks
Ian so we've got three demos for you
today I'm gonna do the first demo and
I'll hand it over to you and do the
second and I'll come back for the third
demo the first demo we're going to do
first thing we're gonna do is connecting
a cluster and logging into it so we're
going to show you how you would actually
go about deploying the connect agent
registering the cluster and then logging
into the cluster will also do a brief
tour both the beginning at the end on
what you get with the UI and then Ian
will spend a lot more time on the UI
piece again so if you wouldn't mind can
you switch this over to the demo screen
okay thank you so here's my cloud
console I went in this is the kubernetes
engine page that you normally get in
here I've got three clusters already
here if you look at them a little
carefully you'll see that they're
actually not normal so I've got an a
chaos cluster here this is an Aes
cluster running on Azure this is a gke
cluster regular GK cluster and I've also
got a GK on Prem cluster that I set up
in San Jose so the reason it's not
normal is this is this is usually filled
with GK clusters now I've got like I
said today we're announcing that you can
register these other clusters and so you
can see all three of these in one spot
so if we click in on the GK on Prem
cluster you'll see that I can get some
very basic information about
I can find out what version of
kubernetes it's running this one happens
to be running 111 I can see the number
of nodes and the total number of cores
and memory if I want to dig down even
further I can see what storage has been
provisioned to it so I can see what PVC
is there I can see the provider of the
of the PVC so this is using vSphere and
I can also see the storage classes that
exist inside this cluster if I click on
nodes I can see even more information
it'll break down those three nodes and
tell me information about the amount of
memory CPU and storage it's available
and I can click on any one of these
nodes and actually see the running
workloads inside them so as you can see
I'm running Prometheus and a few other
things on this on this cluster I can
also see some high-level summaries
around the different resources I'm using
as well as conditions like disk pressure
memory pressure any other types of
issues that we're seeing if I go back to
the cluster list page
I had to zoom in for the purposes of the
demo just so you could see everything on
the screen but there's a new button here
that says register cluster and if I were
to click on that you'll get brought to
this screen here which is a guide it's a
multi-step process to help get it
installed but you'll see how quick the
steps are so the first step is just to
configure the the connect agent the
thing that we're going to install inside
the cluster it turns out I've got a
cluster already ready it's a it's a
cop's cluster that I built on AWS and so
I'm gonna go ahead and name it I'll call
it cops on AWS and the next thing we
need is this service account key and as
you Ian mentioned we need to have a
service account so that we can
authenticate the connect agent that's
running in your cluster back to Google
so when it connects you'll actually
it'll actually show up with a Google
identity that recognizes and it will
offer eyes it to work to do that let's
switch over so you can see on my screen
here I've got two text files and we'll
get to the the the first one actually in
a minute but the second one here the GCP
service account is that service account
so I'm gonna copy that into my paste
buff and then we'll go ahead and paste
that in here if we had a [ __ ] proxy
we could also configure that but we down
in this environment so I'll just hit
continue and I'm presented with a thing
to download so I'll go ahead and
download this man
test file and we'll go ahead and copy
the command that we're going to run when
we hit enter it'll actually go and
install the manifest the agent to
manifest inside the cluster you'll see
it creates a namespace for it itself a
few service accounts and roll back roll
bindings as well as the secret so that
GCP service account ends up being put
into the secret here and finally there's
a deployment tickets that actually has
the agent that's running when it's done
connecting you'll see there's a check
box on the screen that means it's
connected back to Google it's
authenticated itself and we hit continue
here we're going to set some basic
metadata about the cluster so when I
created this I created it in u.s. West
1a on Amazon and provider is AWS we can
also set some other metadata that we
might want to use later for maybe a CI
CD pipeline that can actually look at
the the the key value pairs that we set
on the cluster so let's let's call this
one environment production and we click
register and we're going to be brought
back to the cluster list page and you'll
see that we have our four clusters now
the last one is the new cluster we just
registered and you'll need see that also
we need to log in so anybody who goes to
their Pantheon or their cloud console
right now we get a similar view and they
would also have to log in so when I log
in I'm gonna log in as just myself and
turns out that I am the admin for this
cluster so I'm going to copy the admin
token into there and then we'll go ahead
and just paste that right in here and
click login
Susan done logging in again brought back
to the page and you can see that now I
have more information about the cluster
if we wanted to we could go in and we
could click on this and do the same kind
of exercise we just did but yeah that's
that's it for the first demo if we go
back to the slides real quick so as you
saw we were able to deploy the connect
agent register it the cluster and then
log into it and then we were able to
browse around in the UI I'll now hand it
over to Yoon who will do the next set of
things
thanks Matt sure demo gods are happy
yeah all right so Matt talked about
connecting a cluster I'm actually gonna
talk about monitoring generally
debugging some problems and performing
some updates so the first thing I'm
going to do is look at the workloads and
actually look at the contextual and
actual information that's surfaced
through the UI there is going to be a
problem and so we're gonna kind of dig
into that problem and see how we can
reconcile that problem or solve that
problem we'll make some changes and
actually solve the problem then we're
gonna scale up a deployment so we know
that we're going to need some redundancy
or we're expecting some more traffic so
we'll go ahead and we'll scale up an
application and then finally we've got a
new version of our software that same
software we've we've scaled up and now
we're gonna roll out an update and we're
gonna roll out that update incrementally
using a rolling update that kubernetes
provides please switch over to the demo
no laptop okay so matt was in the
clusterer page and now i'm gonna go over
to the workloads page
we think it's the the Wi-Fi so or the
network connection so should call from
the second guys all right great
so in the workloads page we see a bunch
of different kubernetes objects we get
their names we get you know green check
boxes for the status and then we also
get the type and the pods the namespace
and the cluster that they're running in
and we can see the connect agents from
each of the different clusters and we
can actually see there's something going
on here with this one we don't get that
checkbox so I'm gonna go ahead and I'm
going to click into that to see what's
going on
all right so we can see right away that
there is an error here but before we
dive into the error and really
troubleshoot it I do want to look at the
page a little bit so again we have
information about the cluster with the
name space we have labels that we've set
we can see the replicas here and some
one unavailable zero available that
doesn't look quite right we have the
deployment information the name and the
status we can see that big red
explanation point and information about
the container image that is contained
within this deployment and actually I'm
gonna go ahead will click in here on
show details so what you can see is we
have an application here it's from
Kelsey and there has been a typo by the
developer in terms of what version they
should deploy so it's pretty clear to me
I think we can debug in terms of what we
need to do to resolve this problem so
actually I'm going to click over into
the gamal and here you can see the
deployment and you can see all of that
information in the yamo manifest both in
terms of the metadata and the spec and
even the status down here and we can see
there here the image with that typo so
let's go ahead we're gonna go ahead and
click edit and now we can actually go in
and directly edit this particular image
and application and I'll scroll to the
bottom and I'm gonna hit save now what's
happening is that the UI is actually
deploying the manifest with the updated
image tag and you can see that it's
saying that the pods are pending as it's
making that particular change will just
refresh
this wasn't happening earlier so now we
can see we've got the green checkbox on
hello and also we can see down here the
image tag version and we also see the
number of replicas is one is available
and we can also actually look at the
different pods that are being managed by
this deployment so let's just click in
on that particular pod we can see even
more information and again look into the
different parts of it and let's go ahead
we'll look in on the logs on this
particular pod and so we we got what we
wanted here we see that the server
started up the health service as well as
the HTTP service that is supporting it
so this looks great now we have debug
their problem we've rolled out a change
to the application we've got a green
check box but now we know we only have
one of these so let's go ahead and scale
this up so we get three replicas of this
particular workload so we're gonna go to
the app actions tab here and we're going
to hit scale and so instead of one we're
just going to change this to three and
when I click this button it's going to
declare I want three and what we expect
kubernetes to do is to actually spin up
two more pods like the first one and so
what we see immediately is that we now
want three we only have one two are not
yet up so let's hit refresh and see now
we have the three let's see and we have
the green checkbox on the status we have
three updated three ready three
available all of them are version 1.0
and we can actually click into those
different pods again and if we want to
look at the logs of a different pod we
can see we see those same status
messages that are indicating that
everything is healthy so this is great
now our application has three replicas
running so we can tolerate an out or an
error that would take down one of them
but now our developers have a new
version so now it's time we want to roll
out a new change so I'm gonna go back to
the actions tab and I'm gonna click on
rolling update I've set the min seconds
ready here to ten this is just to kind
of slow things down so we can talk
through it and I'm going to go ahead and
update the image tag to version 2.0 and
so when I click update what's gonna
happen is it's going to declare that I
now want three of the pods running with
version 2.0 and we'll see actually that
it's going to bring up a new version 2.0
and then it's gonna shut down a 100 pod
and then it's going to bring up another
two dotto and shut down and so
eventually we'll have three of the 2.0
pods and zero of the 1.0 pods but it's
going to roll that those updates
so actually we can see here we've got
through we had those three running we
have two creating of the new version and
again up here we see two and two as it's
starting to shut down one of those sit
refresh and see the next state so we
still have some pending we actually have
three of the new ones and one still
shutting down it looks like alright so
now we've got the green check box again
we have version 2.0 we have three of
them running and we can if we wanted to
go and look at the logs again so we have
just shown troubleshooting and debugging
in the UI then we actually made some
changes to resolve the problems then we
scaled it up and then we rolled out an
update so can we switch back to the
slides I'm gonna hand it back to Matt
for the third demo sure thank you again
all right so the last thing we're going
to show you today is how you can deploy
an application from the marketplace to
any one of these connected clusters so
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to quickly choose a cluster
they won't have an application that we
did we choose and configure and then
we'll just go ahead and deploy it and
I'll show you it's actually quite easy
and quick to get started with this so if
we could switch back to the demo that
would be great
could we switch to the computer thank
you
all right so the first thing you notice
is we if we look at the kubernetes
engine tab there's a Marketplace button
I think this actually shows up in pretty
much any any page now but if you click
on marketplace you'll see that there's a
whole bunch of kubernetes app solutions
one of the ones that I'm just going to
show today is just a basic nginx
instance so if we search for nginx
you'll see that we get a list of
solutions if we narrow it down by to
just kubernetes apps we're presented
with this result if we click on that
we'll get a little bit more information
about the solution you can you can read
more about pricing and this one happens
to be free you can learn more about
click to to deploy containers and the
applications themselves but now we want
to deploy this one so let's go ahead and
hit configure and it'll bring us to a
new screen where I've got a lot of
information here so that it allow me to
configure it so I can select amongst any
of those four clusters since I
registered that cops cluster running a
native OS let's go ahead and deploy it
there I can choose what namespaces
deploy it to as well as a number of
replicas let's just choose one to make
it a little bit faster if I hit deploy
now it'll actually use that connection
we've created between your cluster and
Google and it will use the credentials
that I just logged in with and to
actually deploy this application this
turns out it'll take a few minutes to
deploy but if we go over to the
workloads screen actually application
screen you'll see that I actually
previously deployed a wordpress instance
on that same cops in AWS cluster if I go
to the services tab you can see that
we've we've actually exposed the in
nginx ingress that comes with the native
OS cluster and if I click on this it'll
actually bring me to the running
instance of that WordPress app and so
what we've done is we've integrated with
the information that we get out of the
kubernetes objects actually show you the
endpoints running in other other clouds
as well so the really cool part about
this just to summarize if it go back to
the slides for a second is that we were
able to with a few clicks actually
deploy an application from the
marketplace you saw that demo took less
than two
minutes I think and and we actually have
something that that's up and running
which is pretty awesome
and so just to summarize today we
discussed how agility and velocity along
with running anywhere is top of mind
we briefly discussed how anthos is
uniquely positioned to help you meet
your goals and we showed you a feature
of anthos that helps you get visibility
into your workloads that are running
anywhere with it sorry with it you can
quickly easily connect clusters of GCP
interact with in debug workloads through
the UI and even deploy applications to
connected clusters with just a few
clicks we also mentioned that connecting
any kubernetes clusters has just entered
alpha and if you'd like to learn more
participate in the south please contact
your sales representative to express
interest
[Music]